relativ die erste Frage wo ist die
Hoffnung und wo ist die Apokalypse wo
sind sie gerade der Text glaube ich war
aus dem letzten Sommer ne da kam mir
letztes Buch raus genau das ist aus dem
letzten Sommer das Buch heißt ja auch
Countdown und das gibt ja schon so ein
bisschen aus aber da Hoffnung oder Nähe
bei der Apokalypse ja ich werde das sehr
oft in den letzten Tagen auch gefragt
und ich bin irgendwo dazwischen deswegen
sage ich ja ich schwanke zwischen
Hoffnung ab und Apokalypse warum
Apokalypse damit fange ich vielleicht
mal an
weil ich wie die allermeisten ja wissen
schon seit Jahrzehnten über das Klimate
Thema sprechen über das Thema auch ähm
Ozeanographie Zerstörung der Meere und
es wurde ja gerade auch das neue
Klimaschutz erhält das
meeresschutzabkommen gefeiert wo ich
auch so ein bisschen skeptisch bin weil
wir hatten schon so viele historische
Abkommen aber wir sind eigentlich nie
eingehalten worden so dass ich erstmal
abwarten möchte was jetzt bei diesem
Meeres Abkommen
implementiert werden Wert und was nicht
aber wie gesagt ich bin seit Jahrzehnten
dabei und muss leider feststellen dass
wir immer noch in die falsche Richtung
gehen beim CO2 das Hauptproblem beim bei
der globalen Erwärmung ist steigt der
weltweite Ausschuss immer noch und nur
auf den kommt es an das ist ja die Krux
irgendwo dass wir alle buchstäblich im
gleichen Boot sitzen zum Beispiel bei
meeresspiegelanstich ja wir können die
national nicht beeinflussen sondern wenn
tatsächlich dieser weltweite Ausschuss
immer weiter steigt sind wir alle
betroffen und es kommt ja nicht von
ungefähr dass gerade die Polarregion so
dahin schmelzen obwohl dort der
überhaupt kein CO2 ausgestoßen wird also
das ist äh die Apokalypse und auch
letztes Jahr ist der weltweite CO2
Ausstoß gestiegen und ich wann kommen
wir darauf so auf so einem ja das ist
eben nicht zu sehen wenn man sich
einfach die Entwicklung der letzten
Jahrzehnte anguckt geht's eigentlich
immer nur nach oben und alle erwarten
dass es vielleicht mal so ein gibt und
dass wir mal nach unten gehen aber es
passiert irgendwie nicht weil es zwei
konkurrierende Prozesse auf der einen
Seite wir in den Industrieländern
versuchen schon mehr CO2 auszusehen also
zu sagen es passiert nichts wäre
natürlich falsch natürlich passiert
etwas aber es wird ihm überkompensiert
von dem was eben anderen Ort passiert
also wenn ich beispielsweise einer wie
China nehmen 30% gegenwärtig Anteil an
weltweit CO2 Ausstoß und die sind nicht
bereit im Moment das sagen sie auch
wirklich ihren Höhepunkt von CO2
Emission jetzt schnell zu erreichen die
sagen aber ja vielleicht 20 30 oder so
und bei 30 % Anteil kann man sich ja
vorstellen
Deutschland 2% ungefähr zwei im Moment
Deutschland zwei Prozent China ungefähr
30 %. der Anteil Deutschland ist etwas
höher wenn man die historische
Beantwortung berücksichtigt aber
trotzdem
wir müssen einfach erkennen dass es
einige wenige Länder gibt die G20
beispielsweise wenn man die mal nehmen
der die machen ungefähr 80
80 Prozent ja das heißt wir müssten
eigentlich gar nicht darüber
190 Länder auf den Klimakonferenzen
haben eigentlich recht würden
unter den würden sozusagen die Top Ten
auch reichen also wie gesagt das ist der
Apokalypse
Partner andere Partner also das heißt
also es gibt ja Lösung es gibt Ideen und
wir schaffen es einfach nicht ähm diese
Lösung so schnell zu implementieren dass
wir wirklich eine Dynamik entfachen die
es schafft dass wir tatsächlich endlich
mal auf diese schiefe Ebene kommt dass
eben der weltweite Ausstoß tatsächlich
verringert die Hoffnung ist einfach es
wäre so einfach müssen sie wenn sie mich
zum König der Welt machen ja dann müsste
ich ganz genau was ich zu tun hätte und
würden sie machen ich würde erstmal zu
allerersten nein ganz im Gegenteil äh
ich würde allererst die Subvention wenn
es in meiner Macht stünde ja die
Subvention für die fossilen Energien
wegnehmen in dem Moment wo die weg sind
glaube ich haben die neuen Technologien
es relativ einfach den Markt auch
schnell zu erobern und wenn wir erstmal
dabei sind ja dann haben wir ja auch
irgendwie so Lerneffekte ja wenn wir
erstmal anfangen die erneuerbaren
Energien zu nutzen ja dann werden wir
immer besser werden dann werden immer
mehr Menschen sich dafür interessieren
es wird immer neue Geschäftsmodelle
geben und dann passieren die Dinge auf
einmal so schnell womit man gar nicht
gerechnet hat und ich will mein kleines
Beispiel nennen dass das auch geht das
Mobiltelefon wenn sie hätten sie vorher
sagen wir mal 20 Jahren die
Telefongesellschaft gefragt wird sich
das Mobiltelefon durchsetzen haben die
alle ohne Sonne gesagt der verbraucht
denn ein Mobiltelefon ja heute sehen wir
wie schnell wirklich ein
Technologiewandel passieren kann und
noch ein zweiter Punkt in
Zusammenhang sie wir können auch so ein
liebfring machen wie man sagt das heißt
wir
können es auch schaffen dass jetzt
aufstrebende Länder gar nicht unseren
Weg gehen sondern den falschen Weg den
wir gegangen sind überspringen und
gleich den neuen Weg nutzen das
Mobiltelefon hat gezeigt die Afrikaner
gehen jetzt nicht übers Festnetz sie
sind gleich über das Smartphone gegangen
ja
Herr Schröder leg dich mal das war ja in
China letzten Endes genauso ich habe
neulich einen faszinierendes Stück
darüber gelesen warum die die
Digitalisierung in China mit so riesigen
Sprüngen vorangehen weil im Grunde nie
einer vom Laptop gesessen hat und auch
nicht vom vom Stand PC sondern es ging
gleich sozusagen auf das mobile Endgerät
und hat dazu geführt dass alle
Anwendungen von der Sekunde an in der es
dann digital möglich war auf diesen
Smartphones gelaufen sind würden sie
dazu stimmt
zu 100 Prozent relativ nimmt glaube ich
zu ziemlich viel vorweg was ich mir
extra hier zusammengelegt habe aber ich
glaube dass man man auf der einen Seite
unterschätzen wir genau diesen tapping
point der technologisch kommen kann und
ich glaube auch ein Kipppunkt genau in
Kipppunkt kommen kann wo es einfach
keinen Sinn mehr macht ne das schöne an
Sonne und Wind ist dass die
Primärenergie kostenlos ist und es geht
da jetzt in Anführungszeichen nur darum
wie kann ich diese Energie Leistung
anschließen an Mobilität Wärme und Strom
und wir haben jetzt ganz es gibt ganz
viele Probleme und auch Verwerfungen und
so weiter aber ich bin da auch bei Ihnen
auf der Hoffnung Seite weil es
wirtschaftlich so viel potenter ist das
ist eine und wir haben gerade erst den
den Anfang dieser Entwicklung erreicht
ich glaube wir werden das noch erleben
in den nächsten zehn 15 Jahren dass wir
in einer Welt leben die gerade dort wo
wir uns entkoppelt haben von den
fossilen extreme Niedrigpreise erreichen
wird auch für die Industrie und woran
liegt das wenn die Erzeugungsanlagen
erstmal abgeschrieben sind wir müssen
erstmal diesen Wechsel finanzieren das
ist in meinem Einfamilienhaus so das ist
aber eine Industrie genauso wenn sie das
aber einmal gemacht haben dann hat jede
Volkswirtschaft ein Riesenvorteil die
unmittelbar kostenfreie Primärenergie
die sie nicht transportieren muss nicht
elektrisch anschließt und deswegen bin
ich da sehr positiv so so so diese so
diese Idee
ja auch neulich in einem Interview
irgendwo gelesen wo jemand sagte Energie
wird irgendwann nichts mehr kosten das
wird ein Service des Staates sein so wie
Straßenbeleuchtung nachts
volle noch einmal kurz sozusagen dem das
politische Bild noch mal dazu zu malen
ist es nicht ist es nicht wahnsinnig
zynisch eigentlich und perfide dass es
erst den Krieg von Putin in Ukraine
brauchte um an dem Punkt mal richtig den
Turbo anzuwerfen das war mit Sicherheit
ein Turbo in der Tat aber man muss auch
bedenken dass Deutschland jetzt im
internationalen Vergleich schon sich ein
recht ambitioniertes Klimaziele gesetzt
hat wir wollen 20 45 Klima neutral sein
die EU als Ganzes die USA Japan wollen
das 2050 sein China 2016 also wir sind
da schon nicht unangenehm 20 30 80
Prozent aus erneuerbaren Energien haben
ich meine das ist morgen quasi
übermorgen das ist morgen glaube ich na
gut das hängt davon ab wie schnell jetzt
der Ausbau tatsächlich gelingt also
müssen 5,8 wenn Windräder am Tag
schaffen genau die Zahl der Windräder
also generell der Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien muss sich
verdreifachen die Zahl der Wärmepumpen
muss ich vor fünffachen und die Zahl der
Elektroautos muss ich für 15 fahren
damit wir quasi unsere sieben Jahre
stecken in 7 Jahren unsere
selbstgesteckten Klimaziele erreichen ja
genau richtig also das sind alles die 20
30er Zahlen die wir jetzt erreichen
wollen
und das was jetzt passiert ist das habe
ich also Wirtschaftsminister so versucht
das jetzt in die Wege zu leisten das
sind letztes Jahr schon etliche Gesetze
beschlossen worden genau das jetzt zwei
Prozent der Fläche in den Bundesländern
muss für Windkraft reserviert sein es
wurden jetzt die Prozesse vereinfacht
dass es eben nicht mehr sechs Jahre
dauert bis ein Windrad steht sondern das
schneller gehen soll richtig aber ob das
funktioniert das werden wir nach acht
Jahren das waren immer Dinge die
mag man die stellt man sich gerne vor
man sagt er ist ja seine wunderbare Idee
eigentlich ne dass man sozusagen
unendlich saubere Energie zur Verfügung
hat aber jetzt wird plötzlich ganz
konkrete und sie sagten das auch jetzt
werden die deutschen das erste Mal wenn
es konkret was das wirklich bedeutet die
Ansage ab 24 keine neuen Gas und
Ölheizungen mehr und um das mal in den
richtigen Kontext zu stellen
man muss sich dafür mal anschauen wie
viel wir alleine im vergangenen Jahr das
hat mich wirklich umgehauen ich wusste
das nicht allein im vergangenen Jahr
noch mit Gas und Ölheizungen verbaut
haben wie viel war das 600.000
Gasheizungen und knapp 60.000
Ölheizungen von insgesamt ungefähr
900.000 Heizungen die eingebaut wurden
das heißt dieses Gefühl dass wir immer
so haben wie wir gehen jetzt alle eine
ganz andere Richtung und Gasheizung ist
so Retro und Öl ist sowieso totaler das
stimmt gar nicht nee das stimmt
tatsächlich nicht und es ist schon
erstaunlich weil wir ja im vergangenen
Jahr auch großteils noch davon
ausgegangen sind dass wir einen
gasmangel haben werden also das Gas ein
sehr knappes und sehr teures Gut ist
aber es ist eben auch der Punkt dass
viele Gebäude jetzt noch nicht so
geeignet sind nicht so gut gedämmt sind
und energetisch saniert sind dass dort
der Einsatz der von präferierten
Wärmepumpe sich jetzt wirklich gut
eignet von daher gehen jetzt glaube ich
auch viele Leute noch auf Nummer sicher
und sagen ich will Sicherheit haben dass
ich die nächsten Jahre auf jeden Fall
noch heizen kann bevor es jetzt verboten
wird baue ich noch schnell was ein was
dann eben im kommenden Jahr nicht mehr
möglich sein wird also das sind so eine
gewisse Torschusspanik ich vermute mal
wenn dann irgendwann das Aus für den
Verbrenner kommt wird das ähnlich sein
dass dann viele Leute sagen so jetzt
nutze ich noch die letzte Gelegenheit
und kauf mir so ein und dann überlege
ich immer noch weil ich aufs Elektroauto
umsteige lass uns einmal darüber reden
und gern auch die Runde aufmachen weil
alle hier natürlich sich mit dem Thema
auch wirklich gut auskennen sie nennen
das habecks wärmepumpenwunderland ja es
ist Planwirtschaft und die Heizung der
Heizungsbereich ist das Gegenteil von
Turbo Kapitalismus ja es wird halt jetzt
also wenn es wurden bislang immer viele
Zahlen in Gesetze geschrieben oder in
Aktionspläne geschrieben und jetzt ist
halt die Heizungen sind das erste Mal wo
es halt jetzt in der Praxis tatsächlich
Anwendung findet also vom kommenden Jahr
an wird jeder der eine neue Heizung
einbaut ob im Neubau oder in einem
alteren Bestandsgebäude muss die Auflage
erfüllen dass sie zu 65% mit
erneuerbaren Energien betrieben wird und
das kann entweder die Wärmepumpe sein
die mit Strom am besten mit Ökostrom
betrieben wird das kann der Anschluss an
einen kommunales sein gibt es leider
nicht allzu oft und das kann in
bestimmten Fällen auch noch eine
Holzpelletheizung sein wobei die jetzt
auch politisch nicht so gut da stand ist
die meisten Menschenleben auch genau
richtig und da gibt es in der Tat ein
Problem in den Großstädten wäre eher das
Fernwärmenetz geeignet das haben aber
viele Städte ansatzweise ausgebaut aber
eben noch nicht flächendeckend ausgebaut
und was im Moment passiert ist dass die
Politik den privaten
Immobilieneigentümern sehr viele
Auflagen jetzt macht eben wie sie zu
heizen haben aber sie selbst also die
Kommunen sind im Moment noch fein raus
die müssen dann im Jahr später mal sagen
wo sie denn gedenken entfernt werden im
Netz zu installieren aber das ist quasi
schon der Zeitpunkt wo derjenige in
dessen Haus gerade die Heizung kaputt
geht halt vor der Frage steht was mache
ich jetzt das heißt was kommt denn da
auf die Leute zu weil so eine normale
Gasheizung oder Ölheizung was kostet die
ungefähr
eine normale Gasheizung kriegen sie
jetzt je nach Größe das Gebäudes für
unter 10000 €, 8000 €, wenn sie
besonders gut ist und das andere
besonders großes Haus ist vielleicht
15.000 Euro Wärmepumpe
e
der private Eigentümer es soll jetzt
Fördermittel geben also es ist jetzt
klar nach der Aufregung über diese über
diese heizungspläne ist jetzt auch in
der Bundesregierung die Einsicht
entstanden dass das so einfach in wir
schreiben das jetzt ins Gesetz und jeder
muss sehen wir damit zurechtkommt das
ist nicht funktionieren wird also ich
finde diese ganze Diskussion zeigt ja
dass dieses
sektordenken das Denken in Ministerien
überhaupt keinen Sinn macht ja das heißt
also wir brauchen gerade beim
Klimaschutz bei den großen Themen
brauchen wir doch irgendwie so ein
übergreifenden Ansatz ja wir reden
gerade über die soziale Frage auch wer
soll das bezahlen haben sie gefragt ja
das heißt also Sozialpolitik gehört dazu
etwas Politiker gehört dazu
Umweltpolitik gehört dazu wenn das
gerade durch den schrecklichen Krieg
gesehen
Verteidigungspolitik gehört dazu das
heißt also letzten Endes sind alle
Ministerien hier aufgerufen ein Konzept
aus einem Guss
zu entwickeln und genau das passiert
nicht und deswegen rennen wir immer
wieder in diese Probleme die sie eben
gerade thematisieren und diese gerade
uns auch so ja wunderschön wenn ich
jetzt nicht sagen aber so verständlich
dargelegt haben da gibt es aber schon
eine gegenpositionierung ne ich würde
mal sagen also der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister und ich will
es ja auch in Teilen kritisch aber der
hat ja auch eine Aufgabe zu sagen ich
muss irgendwie Industriepolitik machen
was sind denn die Technologien wo
deutsche gut sind dazu gehört die
Wärmepumpe dazu gehört Heiztechnik da
gibt's viele deutsche Anbieter das ist
ein riesiger Wachstumsmarkt den es gibt
es gibt in Schweden oder auch in anderen
Ländern schon Länder die viel günstiger
in der Gesamtkosten Betrachtung
co2-seitig und stromkostenseitig damit
fahren das heißt ja die
Anschaffungskosten sind hoch aber die
Betriebskosten sind günstiger günstiger
als bei einer Gasheizung kann man drüber
streiten aber ich würde mal sagen
zumindestens pari und Strompreis so hoch
ist schwierig genau
also ich denke klar es gibt da auch
Möglichkeiten das Photovoltaik
Eigenverbrauch das heißt es gibt nicht
der das machen kann aber es gibt sehr
wohl tolle Beispiele und es sind 100.000
und Millionen von Einfamilienhäusern die
können das machen das heißt die können
Geld sparen die können CO2 sparen
deswegen würde ich mal sagen
industriepolitisch würde ich jetzt Herrn
habe ich nicht unterstellen dass das so
falsch ist weil wir müssen ja auch Dinge
tun die eine Planbarkeit reinbringen in
die Industrie das will die Industrie
immer wieder das ist richtig deswegen
würde ich sagen würde ich mal sagen da
kann man Haken hinter machen beim
Wirtschaftsministerium und der zweite
Punkt ist ja auch und das ist genau das
wir müssen ja Sachen machen die müssen
geeignet sein das heißt die müssen
geeignet sein die müssen umsetzbar sein
sie müssen da sein und wir müssen auch
zeitlich effektiv sein das 1,5 Grad Ziel
geht vor allem auf Zeitlichkeit ja und
deshalb würde ich jetzt sagen dass es
ist auf jeden Fall deutlich besser als
nichts zu machen die Frage ist halt ne
was sind was ist denn dieser Gesamtheit
vorschlagen
man braucht halt die Akzeptanz der
Menschen und die Akzeptanz haben sie nur
wenn die alternativen da sind und wenn
sie auch in der Praxis funktionieren
vielleicht nur mal als Beispiel Dänemark
wird immer so als Musterland genannt
weil die schon vor etlichen Jahren das
verboten haben was jetzt auch bei uns
kommt nämlich den Einbau neuer fossiler
Heizungen aber angefangen hat Dänemark
damit Anfang der 70er Jahre als nämlich
die Ölkrise war und Dänemark war sehr
stark hat viel mit Öl geheizt und dann
entstand so das Denken okay wir müssen
davon weg wir fangen jetzt an ein
kommunales Wärmenetz aufzubauen und erst
im Jahr 2013 also 70er Jahre 2013 kam
dann tatsächlich das Verbot so in
Neubauten keine neuen Öl und Gasheizung
und ein paar Jahre später dann auch in
Bestands Bauten und heute heizen dort
ungefähr zwei Drittel der Haushalte in
Großstädten wie Kopenhagen nahezu alle
Haushalte eben mit Fernwärme es gab eine
Alternative und ich glaube das ist so
ein bisschen das was mich hier im Moment
etwas sorgenvoll stimmt ist dass wir
jetzt in einer sehr großen Zeitung wir
wollen alles auf einmal wir wollen halt
jetzt quasi übermorgen diesen Wechsel
das liegt natürlich auch daran dass so
viele Jahre relativ wenig passiert ist
keine Frage und wir haben dieses
ambitionierte Ziel und das ist wichtig
dass wir ambitionierte Ziele haben aber
ich glaube schon man darf also die
Politik muss die Leute mitnehmen
finanziell und auch
bevor wir gleich zu Herrn
ist nämlich ein super Beispiel weil
nicht nur industriepolitisch sondern
auch sozialpolitisch ist der CO2-Preis
über 100 € pro Tonne ja also viel viel
höher als bei uns hat aber keine
sozialen Verwerfung gegeben oder keine
Gesellschaft weil die halt eben
gleichzeitig auch die soziale Komponente
mit berücksichtigen andere Steuern
abgeschafft ja und haben eben auch
soziale Projekte gefördert deswegen ist
es entsteht gut gegangen und deswegen
habe ich eben gesagt wir müssen wirklich
hier ein Politik aus einem Gott haben
und das sagen sie auch Frau Löhr wir
können nicht einfach sagen jetzt hauen
wir sozusagen
die neuen Techniken einfach hier ganz
schnell rein ohne zu sehen können die
Menschen das auch wirklich mitgehen und
wenn die Menschen es nicht mitgehen
können werden wir eine riesen
Problematik bekommen bei der
gesellschaftlichen Akzeptanz aber
nochmal ganz kurz ne also Dänemark weiß
ich ist mittlerweile knapp 80 oder mehr
Prozent erneuerbare Energien dann
wahnsinnige Windparks und so weiter die
sind quasi unabhängig den war Putin und
Gaslieferungen das hat die nie wirklich
tangiert zwar den faktische egal die
Schweden haben Atomkraftwerke gelaufen
nicht unwichtig in dem Zusammenhang wir
reden hier über Strom also wir reden
darüber dass wir mit Strom letzten Endes
heizen auch wenn wir sozusagen technisch
den Umweg über Wärmepumpen nehmen am
Ende bleibt es Strom wichtig dass den
Leute immer klar zu machen so und die
andere Frage ist wir sind ein
hochtechnologie-land wir sind unfassbar
Energie hungrig unsere
Wertschöpfung kommt zu einem guten Teil
also Industrieproduktion muss ich
anschaut Industrie intensiver Betriebe
BASF und so weiter Armonia hat
Produktion ein Teil also die Hälfte
davon runter gefahren machen die nicht
mehr weil es schlicht und ergreifend
nicht mehr darstellbar ist das heißt
diese soziale Frage wenn sie sagen das
wird dann dreimal so teuer werden wie
das was wir jetzt haben das ist doch
etwas was man Ernstes aber nicht
korrekte teuer betraf jetzt die
Wärmepumpe als ich installiere dieser
Heizung ja
die Betriebskosten das sind die
Anschaffungskosten deshalb muss schon
mal differenzieren das eine ist was
kostet mich die Schröder ich weiß aber
wenn wir so diskutieren
auf einem anderen Planeten unterwegs
unfassbar weit weg von den Leuten ich
ich weiß irgendwie auch in den Alpen es
ist wichtig ne das ist die Bude warm ist
das große die große Angst meiner Mutter
muss mal ganz praktisch zu machen war
immer hoffentlich geht die Ölheizung
nicht kaputt weil wenn sie kaputt geht
dann werden echtes Problem und und
Menschen die nicht 10.000 100.000 €
verdienen die haben ein Problem damit 40
50 60.000 € zu investieren ist ein
riesiges Thema das doch eine ganz andere
Frage ob du 15.000 investierst oder
50.000 investierst und dann sitzt du
dann hast dir 10000 € abgespart um eine
neue Gasheizung zu kaufen und dann sagt
die plötzlich jemand pass auf läuft
nicht mehr ich habe ein anderes Beispiel
und das zeigt die ganze Absurdität wir
haben ungefähr 4 Millionen gasbetriebene
Etagenheizungen in Deutschland so die
hängen mehr Familienhäuser
wenn nur eine Anzeige davon in einer
Wohnung kaputt geht dann soll nach
diesem Gesetzentwurf die ganze
Hausgemeinschaft innerhalb von sechs
Jahren ein neues Konzept vorlegen wie in
Zukunft geheizt werden kann und da
bleiben noch mal drei Jahre Zeit um das
umzusetzen so es Leute die also gerade
in eine neue Gastherme eingebaut haben
eine neue Gastherme müssen die dann
trotzdem entsorgen ist das sozial das
wird jetzt nach und nach tatsächlich auf
alle Eigentümer zu kommen weil 2045
nicht mehr mit fossilen geheizt werden
soll darf so wird das ein Gesetz stehen
also nach und nach wenn alle mit Leuten
die sich das nicht leisten können da
kommt jetzt quasi der Schritt die
Fördermittel also jetzt nach dem großen
Aufschrei über diese Pläne der auch
schon etwas überraschend war weil das
stand schon im Koalitionsvertrag so drin
aber sei
gibt es jetzt einen einen ja ein
Sinneswandel und man sagt okay wir
müssen da mehr abpuffern und können das
nicht in einzelnen Eigentümern quasi
alles auflasten und für Geringverdiener
soll es jetzt Förderprogramme geben man
muss dazu sagen auch heute gibt es schon
Unterstützung finanzieller Art also wenn
sie jetzt heute neue Wärmepumpe bei sich
zu Hause einbauen bekommen Sie wenn Sie
diverse Voraussetzungen erfüllen 40% der
Kosten wenn sie nicht ganz so viele
erfüllen 25 Prozent der Kosten erstattet
also es gibt Unterstützung schon heute
und die soll für Geringverdiener dann
noch aufgestockt werden aber die Frage
ist natürlich was ist mit denen die eben
jetzt nicht die geringste sind sondern
die die Mittelschicht sind jetzt
vielleicht auch in ländlichen Regionen
wohnen in Nordhessen Thüringen ich weiß
nicht wo halt dann ein Familienhäuser
auch mal schnell weniger als 100.000
Euro wert sind und die sich dann jetzt
für 30.000 € abzüglich Fördermittel
Wärmepumpe einbauen sollen und wo ist
kein Fernwärmenetz gibt also da
es wird spannend werden zu sehen wie
dann die Stimmung sich entwickelt und ob
dann tatsächlich auch diejenigen die in
mir in Umfragen immer sagen wir sind für
Klimaschutz und das ist alles ganz
wichtig dann tatsächlich sagen okay ich
investiere das jetzt ich ziehe damit wir
machen das jetzt